what's up everyone we're sitting down
with sunny Jane the founder of Sun
genomics thanks for having me on the
show I'm excited to talk to you about
flora and the microbiome yeah exactly so
now we're gonna be talking about what
Sun genomics actually does with all of
this crazy microbiome information so
we've realized that there is a real
challenge when you're trying to think
about how to manage your microbiome in
fact I had microbiome anxiety not
knowing what are the microbes inside of
my gut if they're equal to my human
cells I would like to know a little bit
more about them if I'm gonna host them
yes and you know these are guests
they're coming they're living in my
house yeah they're eating my food so I'd
like to know who they are and we've
created one of the best x-rays into your
gut to enable people to understand their
microbiome and then provide them with
solutions so that they can actually
manage their microbiome so not just
recommendations for exercise and diet
but an action in a precision probiotic
that's targeted to your specific unique
microbiome yes this is exciting I want
to know who these guests are and how I
can best work together with them
absolutely and and not all guests are
equal right so some of our good guests
they help you do the dishes afterwards
right and then there's some guests that
are jumping in the pool and and causing
a lot of splash around the around the
the patio so so we want to understand
the balance there yeah and let's let's
visit your site here for us to kind of
get a better idea of some genomics so
here we're on your landing page we have
you know know your gut control your
health again it's like no these guests
who are these guests let's talk about
these guests and understand them and
here's the you know your home's your
guts home to millions of bacteria make
up your unique microbiome and so then
you create custom probiotics to help
restore balance and give complete
control of health so now as we scroll
the
you know we have a little like shout out
to Indy bio you know the company that
was the seed stage of your acceleration
into the world one of the largest
biotech accelerators yeah it was a
privilege to be a part of classics at
Indy bio and great mentorship that they
provided to us yeah totally and then
it's good I like how you got a short
video up and I really enjoy how you know
the companies that can that can showcase
kind of like really animated and
friendly ways of understanding what is
going on at a complex level inside of
you is really like especially with with
animations yeah exactly and not only you
know the complex information of the
microbiome but then you know what do you
actually do once you know your
microbiome and you you try to go to the
store the first consumer solution is is
a probiotic you try to go to the store
to select one and you'll quickly realize
how challenging of a decision that is
you know we have so many choices are
ready as products but now imagine taking
that to a hundredth level of degree of
choice decision making because there are
hundreds of strains of probiotics to
choose from oh yeah that was right here
that was right here at the store yeah
that's right and this guy's like this
guy's like what do I do
there's so many to choose from I saw
this guy at the store the other day come
by the probiotic aisle and he was trying
to figure out what to purchase and then
his family came by and said come on
let's go and he's like alright I guess
I'm not gonna buy one today and then
leaves
he wanted to buy probiotic but there's
so many just took too long to make the
decision and to know what specifically
good for you when there's so many
options exactly exactly and providing
this concierge service so you can just
go online register at Sun genomics com
we'll ship you your microbiome
collection kit and at your convenience
you collect a micro stool sample you
send it back to the lab we're gonna give
you your full microbiome report
so you can understand now all the guests
in your house yes and we're also going
to provide you with precision probiotics
so you can think of that as like the the
party favors for the guests and and and
to make the party really at positive I
guess for your gut and so we're
providing precision probiotics that are
custom tailored to your microbiome yes
and so then in order to understand the
microbiome you go on a son genomics comm
you order the kit the kit comes we take
a micro sample of the stool send it back
then you are analyzing it the whole
genetic composition of the of the gut
bacteria yeah and then after that then
you make a out of you have a you have a
library of probiotics and then you make
a decision on a couple of the strains of
probiotics to send to the individual
that was one of the first studies we did
so we studied probiotics by the hundreds
and we tested the ones off the shelf
only found that 85% of the probiotics
off the shelf don't even survive the
gastric system so they don't get through
that stomach acid to get to your
intestines where all that absorption is
occurring and if you can't get the
probiotics there then you have obviously
don't get the benefits of them and then
we also tested the DNA level that there
are strains within these products not
listed on the label so we're identifying
organisms that are not necessarily good
for you and that can be dangerous at
times if you're taking things that are
not really going to be in sync with your
microbiome yeah and we've created now a
solution where our strains in our
repository are going to be able to
survive the gastric system they're
exactly the strains that are matched to
your microbiome very personalized
ninety-day set of precision probiotic
pills that we deliver back and on a 90
day set I'm taking a once per day yeah
once per day we're gonna provide a prime
solution for you at the beginning just
to get used to these new microbes that
are part of your microbiome and then
you'll switch to flourish and that will
be the modulating dose
in this post that flora or is the whole
process for it the whole process yeah is
flora it's it's a take on flora
yeah the flora of your gut and being
able to improve it
and I like how you because then you have
a brand for flora is the process of
analyzing your microbiome and providing
probiotics and then now son genomics can
also potentially take another process
you can have another name for a
different process as well yeah that's
right and we're also focused on deep
research working on next-generation
probiotics thinking about the microbes
in our gut and what can benefit billions
of people and putting those back into
our food sources so that so that we can
live healthier lives and then how long
do we have to stay like if we if we come
back here we see that you know we're
doing precision probiotics to get a
better diversity going on in our gut
have better nutrition better performance
now how how long like we do 90 days when
am I getting benefits how do I know that
I'm getting my benefits as and we're
taking another sample and then you're
analyzing it and showing me the feedback
after 90 days and then do I need to take
another 90 yeah all good questions
around you know getting that real
feedback loop to yourself it's an
engagement for yourself about your
microbiome the first thing that you
hopefully experience is is some
phenotypic changes either to mood or to
movements or potentially tiny things
like gaseous or bloating that you're
experiencing if you have more chronic
conditions it may take a little bit
longer but there's an objective way to
measure that right so we're actually
gonna retest you after three months and
then we're gonna actually see those
microbes change and you'll actually see
our probiotic strains show up in your
profile giving you the confidence that
they survive the gastric system and then
what contribution they've made to your
overall microbiome as well and that's
you know two levels of things and we
also provide a portal for you to track
all the information cool weekly feedback
onto
you're feeling how are things improving
and we're here for you where we're the
concierge service around your gut health
you text us you email us you let us know
how things are going I like the idea of
also having a portal where I can see the
retest and how exactly it has affected
me over the 90 days and and then
actually be able to see your probiotics
in action and and we'll break that down
more a little bit more about the maybe
some concerns some average Q&A that
people have we'll talk about that in our
next little sit-down thanks guys for
tuning in and thanks sunny from Sun
genomics check out the link in the bio